what took him so long
radical manhattan d.a alvin bragg
finally dropping the bogus second-degree
murder charge against that hard-working
bodega clerk who was acting in
self-defense when he stabbed a career
criminal felon who attacked him over the
price of a bag of chips new york city
mayor eric adams celebrating the news
while sounding off on the crime wave
i think in this case we had an innocent
hard-working new yorker that was doing
his job and someone was extremely
aggressive towards him
and i believe after the da's review the
d.a in my opinion made the right
decision the goal is this continuous
battle
of
making sure dangerous people
that are arrested
are prosecuted go through the criminal
justice system and off our streets we
continue to have this catch release
repeat mindset we got to get that under
control being able to defend yourself
against criminals in liberal cities
taking on more urgency especially with
these headlines nypd data show major
crime in the big apple up a whopping 37
percent over the last year as violent
crime in chicago sword arrest fell to
historic lows
i think that judge can't the mayor be a
little bit more to use his words
aggressive when it comes to
kind of taking shots at the d.a
you know
this mayor i've said it before he's all
talk and for a guy who's actually walked
the walk as a police captain he's all
talk he's he's all hat no cattle or
whatever
this is a guy what did you say i
disagree i don't care
okay let me explain something to you i
was a prosecutor
and a judge for more than three decades
this is the kind of behavior that can be
stopped you've got a d.a who's a
half-wit it takes him three weeks to
figure this out it's all on video you've
got a career criminal gang banger who is
limiting a guy in terms of his his area
which that confinement in itself allows
a guy to use a certain amount of defense
he's half his age and twice as strong
the evicted the defendant in this case
the owner says look i want no trouble
papi he reasonably believed that his
life was in danger and he stabbed him
period end of the story it's on video my
concern is for all those people all
those bodega owners and mom and pop
stores that don't have videos that don't
have the ability to get the
the city behind them to get fox news
behind them to get jesse waters behind
them they don't have that but we're
going to give illegals phones we're
going to fly them all over the country
we're going to make sure they got
education medication and everything else
we ought to take care of ourselves first
and that's the sad part now when this
mayor talks about tax release cash
release we got to change the mindset
mayor get your butt over to albany take
down governor hochul take down andrea
stewart cousins and carl heasey and tell
him if you don't stop this catch and
release which is usually a border term
but what's going on with criminals then
you're gonna break from the democratic
ideology you are a democrat politician
because you will not break from that
this is about releasing them on jail and
everybody else being a victim and i'm
done
maybe you can answer the judge's
question why did it take the d.a so long
to drop these charges well i i am
absolutely a critic of this district
attorney just as i am an advocate of
this mayor eric adams i believe that he
is doing the right thing saying all the
right things he's tireless he's going
everywhere he was early on this he knew
that that was self-defense even before
the district attorney did the district
attorney in his own defense says he did
not see the video before they charged
attempted murder or murder 2 rather
in this particular case
listen you know
new york is is a great big machine 8
million people it takes a while to
change these trends we've got we had de
blasio for eight years we had the worst
possible leadership uh hands-off uh you
know uh the rights of the defendant
paramount uh don't put him in rikers
island it's too uh it's too arduous it's
too uh draconian in there uh you know it
new york is coming around new york is
coming around this was a self-defense
case no one disputes that now
he was as the judge says in reasonable
belief that uh you know he needed to use
force to save his own life uh and i
think that it's as gruesome as it is let
this be an example that the bodegas is
not now going to fight back not only are
they going to fight back but the city
administration is going to be behind
them the neighborhood watchers are going
to be behind them the other bodega
owners are going to be behind them the
community itself will reject the notion
that these these uh these these thieves
these arrogant uh entitled thieves
can uh can have free reign well geraldo
mentioned the d.a said that he didn't
even look at the video before charging
the guy with murder dana why rush
a charge why not just wait until you
have all the evidence collected and then
make a charting decision
this is a good outcome today
this is justice today but it was really
delayed and that is almost to be then
denied because not only did they charge
them with second-degree murder they took
him straight to rikers yeah they're in a
riker's prison and his stab wounds from
the girlfriend who still did not get
charged
then he they got infected
and this is a guy who's now
where does he get his apology
and also thank goodness for the new york
post fox news and uh retired nypd
inspector paul morrow wrote a piece for
foxnews.com that really helped lay it
all out we all drove on this where was
aoc yeah good point where were any of
the new york local where was chuck
schumer did you ever hear from him i
don't think so where was the new york
times
and this is supposed to your city
you're the ones that are the that want
to see everybody come back to work you
want to see the city flourish then you
have to start figuring out a way to put
pressure on alvin bragg as finally the
mayor did i think this is a good outcome
but i still think that alba is deserved
deserves an apology especially for that
trip to rikers he did not deserve that
yeah where was aoc greg
i don't know maybe she was getting
arrested you know uh just the other
point too is like gofundme dropped the
campaign to help this guy but they're
still like helping out a lot of other
people that are actually on the other
side of the law did that went to to what
you were saying the decision to dump
these charges wasn't based on any
politician or anything but public
outrage this is a reminder that if you
want to stop the insanity you can i
think the bodega owners coming together
you had the media you had i'd have to
take credit for almost 90 of this you
deserve it i do i do i'm a target yes
i'm a tireless advocate no but i mean
you know jesse brought it up paul morrow
put writing for the the new york post
foxnews.com
uh this was getting people to we're
getting to the moment now
where we're kind of like where the
bertie gets
stories stick with you because we live
in this fast-paced world where horrible
crimes are happening every day i mean we
how much time do we spend on the race
car driver
or the olympic athlete i mean these
things are now like why this morning you
got shot in the face yes on the lawn
order oh yeah yeah yeah the law and
order said so you know i think this is
what happens when you accept progressive
rhetoric without checking under the hood
right we're all so scared of questioning
things that sound compassionate like
christian
criminal justice reform you know who's
not for that that sounds great criminal
justice reform everybody liked reform
except it benefited the criminal and not
the victim it's all it was new terrain
at least in my lifetime the first time
in history where we flip the script and
put the put the victimizers before the
victims it's all now about like radical
this is all from the campuses radical
worshipping of the oppressed when in
fact they're actually criminals again
where the feminist groups when the
majority of these uh victims are women
we had two women sexually assaulted uh i
think it was yesterday last night early
morning uh in the streets of new york
and you just never see these where the
feminist groups when the majority
of the victims are women by psychopaths
pushing them in front of trains pushing
them downstairs hitting them with
objects where are they it's a fair
question i mean the governor is going
back and forth on her helicopter
albanita god knows where what the hell
what the hell she doing nothing she
should fire alvin bragg right now or
we're going to fire her when she's up
for election but she'll probably go
anyway all right by the way speaking of
which de blasio yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else